today we're gonna murder some people
with fire
[Music]
you
welcome to yandere simulator my name is
pierre de ba listen if someone hits on
your girl or your or your boy or your
dog you got to pay the back you got to
pay it forward just like that one movie
so we're gonna murder them but first
there's a couple things you need to do
number one get a bucket [ __ ] bucket step
2
filled a bucket step 3 try to fish Dilys
what's the meaning of basilisk bas il i
sk oh my [ __ ] god let's stay on
target
we need bucket [ __ ] nice hat
[ __ ] can I have my bucket bag thanks
guys that's just that's just okay okay
alright you're ready for this poor
[Music]
oh oh let's check her out
where is she where the [ __ ] is she hey
come back here hey can I have my water
back please come on bad back
come on oh never mind you can keep the
water all right let's get some good
shots oh my lord
holy [ __ ] bikini split oh my lord oh oh
holy o holy holy holy moly all right we
played enough with water now let's get
into the real business gasoline but to
do this we need five things that's right
you guessed it right
five panty shots we need five panty
shots Q of the panther shark montage
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
no better [ __ ] work where's your
doing business with you I just got my
bucket of piss nothing weird or
suspicious about it
oh there [ __ ] there's just oh god she's
close to senpai that [ __ ]
she's gonna get what she deserves gosh
don't worry you can dry yourself with
this now God don't you [ __ ] run away
from me come on come on come on come on
hey hey hey hey where are you going oh
god damn it we got to hurry yet she's
gonna wash yourself
[ __ ] [ __ ] we're that much time we're
that much time god damn it yeah
cool girls don't look at burning up
their friends they just whoa my god that
should teach you not to [ __ ] with senpai
hi guys just dev just brought my guys
it's normal what it was it's my carpet
there's one more way you can [ __ ] well
actually there's many but we're gonna do
one more way to [ __ ] with this girl
first off you got to level up your
strengths which you can do with click of
a button you take the dumbbells you
place the dumbbells you carry those say
holy [ __ ] I'm [ __ ] strong man you
could walk up to the ceiling but [ __ ] it
and now we play the waiting game there
she is okay here we go drop
[Music]
Oh can't be no it can't be
oh my god and now for the conclusion of
this video oh my gosh damn it [ __ ]
hell dude
well that it's been another successful
episode of yandere simulator if you
enjoyed please go ahead and leave a like
I love playing this game check out the
development in the description and
support the developer that's it for me
for now and as always stay awesome press
you're just finished for the rest of
your life but it will be ok you're in
safe hands now just [ __ ] kidding
you're dead to me
giraffe son of a [ __ ]